nearly two years after the capital Riot
the house January 6th committee released
its findings this week the 814 page
report calls the events of that day
unimaginable and places the blame for
the deadly attacks squarely on the
shoulders of former president Donald
Trump in a video posted to his social
media platform last night Trump tried to
shift blame to Congressional leaders for
not having proper Security in place at
the Capitol but the man in charge of
Homeland Security in Washington that day
says the attack on the capitol was not
an intelligence failure Jeff bagais has
that story
January 6 was certainly uh in my view
the most significant terrorist attack on
the United States since 9 11.
Christopher Rodriguez does Mrs
actual was the result of an intelligence
failure you don't think it was no uh the
it was not an intelligence failure or
failure to share intelligence CBS News
has obtained what are among the most
detailed intelligence documents law
enforcement had at that time
they outlined the threat that incidence
of violence are likely to occur at least
20 groups several with a history of
espousing violent intent will congregate
some will carry firearms among those
groups neo-nazis White supremacists and
The Oath Keepers Rodriguez who worked at
the CIA has experience planning for
potential attacks
leading up to January 6 he planned for
worst case scenarios including then
president Trump could call his
supporters to action perhaps by tweeting
that no one should be standing by any
longer and ultimately invoking the
Insurrection act federalizing the D.C
National Guard and local police until
the National Emergency was over you had
to game plan all the different potential
scenarios yes and that was one of them
yes
that we could not depend on the federal
government to support us
at a walk where he says committee
confirmed for president Trump's
supporter
armed cameras captured members and The
Oath Keepers marching up the capital
steps in formation
to quell the violence local law
enforcement needed
federal law enforcement a call from the
White House would have expedited that
help
as the January 60 mini pointed out that
coal came too late it really was a
failure to act and to posture to the
intelligence in its final report the
committee alleged that Trump refused to
act as the riot unfolded that he watched
the riot on television the intelligence
was there about the strong potential for
violence to this day the former
president maintains that he did nothing
wrong on January 6th and that the
investigation is a Witch Hunt for CBS
Saturday morning Jeff begays in
Washington